so our next and last
speaker says that she is a mainstream
millennial
she likes bicycles i hope it's a fixie
not just any old bicycle but a fixie
beer mountains and pub trivia though
something that sets her apart from all
the other millennials is that she didn't
get into baking during the pandemic
so please everyone welcome mo
hi hi everyone um thanks jared i
actually um i have a gravel bike so
the second best bike for a typical
hipster millennial um i'm really
delighted to be here um
and i know that i'm the only thing
keeping us from kind of socializing in
happy hour and i hope to meet a lot of
y'all there i am maureen but most people
call me mo
and i've been a part of insight lane for
the past
year and a half or so and i'll be
talking about
recently launching a pilot program to
partner with cities
vision stereo initiatives um this talk
might be a little bit more
kind of policy focused uh than than
code focus but hopefully we'll have a
bit of fun with that
um so i often live in cities cyclists
like
i said but i'm also a driver subway user
pedestrian park lover and much much more
my background is in public health
research so uh most recently for the
past
10 months or so i've been working in
cobit and kind of getting back
to my roots i've also been involved in
the tech ethics and data
equity groups and i'm primarily a
qualitative analysis
but i'm excited to be here because uh
the past 10 months in particular i've
been learning r
to unlock some mixed methods research
opportunities and this
open source project is one of the ways
that i'm hoping to use some of this new
found
skill and knowledge so insightlane
it's a volunteer-driven completely open
source platform
that assesses and visualizes crash risk
across road networks i'll go into it a
little bit more exactly how we do that
um but really it was uh born out of the
idea that we wanted to
to inform benefit any residents or city
governments or any other stakeholder for
the purpose of improving car bike
and pedestrian infrastructure which is
part of the reason i emphasize that i
do all of those things in cities and i
suspect
a lot of y'all do too we really also
support
volunteer skill building i can speak on
that first hand um
two of the main core volunteers that
have been involved with the project for
almost four years
ben and jenny have really become good
friends have supported things that i'd
like to do
and i've learned a lot as we've shared
knowledge and contribute and
built kind of community as well which is
really important during this time when
we're all
really mainly digital and trying to stay
as safe as possible
um the big goal for insight lane is to
really provide a tool to assess crash
risk
we want it to be easy we want it to be
deployable we want it to be used it's
based on open source technology we use
open street maps um everything's on
github
we also want the tool to be able to be
applied to any road network
for a couple different reasons this is
somewhat limited to cities because
they're bounded
we would also like people to be able to
initialize their city and add features
with minimal technical overhead
so the platform is widely can be widely
applied
but with individualized data from city
which i'll go into a little bit more
and then of course this is kind of the
policy piece or the advocacy piece
is that at the end of the day um what
good is the platform if it doesn't
provide kind of interpretable actionable
resource
results even if it's fun to build um
yeah so this is the basic kind of
process of how we
do it so any city can provide crash data
it goes through our we configure it um
you can add point-based features
uh cut which to any sort of crash data
set
um it gets processed then we model it um
we create kind of individualized uh
segments that are
consisted of different open street
segments we create a model
which generates a set of risk scores for
each uh road segment
and then we also have a visualization
that i'll show you um
in the end um this is kind of a repeat
of that but some of the
kind of cool things that i like about it
is that each segment
is uh basically analyzable and you can
add features to each one of those so
that makes it a little bit different
than some of the other
vision zero kind of analyses that often
look at density
rather than kind of segment based
analysis we also split it into bike
pedestrian and vehicle
so you can see risk for each one of
those kind of transportation modes
along a road network we predict a
model-based risk score
um across all the segments that goes
from zero to one and is city based so a
0.5 in boston
would not be the same as a 0.5 in
philadelphia rather you could look at it
within city
um so it's really really individualized
um we also can make different
recommendations
uh let's say that you want to get to
you want to see like basically two
different routes getting to see city
hall
which one is a higher risk route and
that might tell you some things about
like
the accessibility of that neighborhood
to a particular point on a map
and then we also visualize it and have
an interactive map which i would
encourage you all to look check out on
our website which i'll share at the end
um here's an example of kind of the
route level risk scores so this is
in boston and we basically looked at two
points
arriving at city hall and the
blue zone is the lowest risk
for a particular one mile or two mile
segment leading to city hall
and the red is the highest risk score
just note that because it is a risk
score this doesn't mean like that uh
it doesn't correlate one-on-one with
crashes rather it's a predictive
risk score um
we are in multiple cities one of our
first uh vol
volunteers was from boston which is why
we started there but then we had several
volunteers come in from
australia and have a couple cities in
australia too this is an example
of what you can see on our website where
we generate
help basically say what are the highest
risk segments in a particular city
and also generate risk scores in this
case i screenshot
a map from the bicycle
risk segments in brisbane australia
so what led us to launching a pilot
initiative to partner with cities
um you know at the beginning this would
have been back in 2016.
um we were a bunch of us were part of
kind of an open source group called data
for democracy
and people were very excited about using
data to support different
policy initiatives or even just to kind
of geek out about it
one of the volunteers was the chief data
officer of
boston and kind of brought the idea that
there's
traffic crashes are increasing vision
zero initiatives regaining popularity
um when boston took on a vision zero
initiative they sought help from its
community in order to accomplish some of
its goals
um so the team got together 2016
really focused on boston initially and
that really still is where the
the a bunch of most of our data analysis
is
um it was initially called crash model
project which we expanded to insight
lane
in 2018 we expanded to many other cities
about 10 which i'll show in a minute
um and then in 2019 it was a little bit
of a pause uh
for us um it was about maintaining the
pipeline and kind of reflecting on what
this would actually do
um i joined sometime in 2019 when i was
trying to find
an additional project to really sink my
teeth into
and we kind of came up together that
like one of the things we could do to
revitalize and relaunch the project
was to actually kind of show cities how
we could
potentially help them and i'll go a
little bit through the process on how
we had to think about doing that because
it's
i think there are always some um
really interesting like communication um
goals when you're communicating with
maybe a government or a stakeholder
who may or may not have the same um kind
of coding background
um and with a coding project
so one of the things this may not seem
really basic but i think it's also
important um we were initially part of
kind of like a
consortium of different open source
projects we decided that if we were
going to be reaching out to city we
needed to do
some communication and branding work so
we made a local logo
we got our own twitter account and we
have a website
and we just felt that that would be kind
of um along the communication
um like expectations of being able to
reach out to
cities that might be looking for some
sort of data-driven
analysis to support their policy work
again started in boston the platform was
built to be used in any city
i listed some of them here most recently
as part of the new initiative we've
reached out to charlottesville virginia
and austin texas
i'm actually from uh texas but north of
north of boston so that's been really
fun
so i'm gonna try an interactive
experiment and this is part of kind of
uh maybe the meta that every city is is
a little bit different
so i am going to tweet real quick what i
wrote here
um and i would love if you can either
share what city you're in
either in the chat or on twitter where i
just tweeted um
where or something that you love about
transport or a particular memory you
have or maybe
if you think your city might be
interested in having
the crash modeling platform that we've
built be used
um i'll go into some of the options for
cities uh
in a couple of slides and maybe if if
people
let me make sure press that uh if people
are actually respond then i'll try to
read some out loud
at the end so a couple things that
values that drive
uh the partnership uh to think about
like while we're thinking about like the
different cities that we
have chosen is that cities have multiple
stakeholders um you're a stakeholder
in the city where you live you might be
part of a advocacy organization you
probably voted or or participated
somehow in the election that happened
a month ago and i think it's good
interesting to always think like what
what questions might you have about your
neighborhood or your city what might you
change or create
um we really want to support
participatory collaborative democracy
because we have a platform that can be
broadly used each city but
at the same time each city has its own
data constituents and concerns
you know most of us live in either
boston and i live in texas
um so we don't know what's going on in
new orleans for instance and would
really
want to support the kind of local
voluntarism and participatory action
there and then also like really
emphasizing that volunteers and
stakeholders are welcome to co-create
and build
on um what we do so we have had people
come in
uh initialize our city uh with the crash
data and
do a few things but then we never see
them again but as long as it's getting
used we're really happy
so as we've started to do this outreach
really
in the past three or so months we've
kind of noticed
two different scenarios that seem to be
popping up
both in our previous work that we've
done with boston and other cities
and then also with what we're doing now
so some city governments already have
done crash analysis
and really have a digital platform
similar to ours that was the case with
boston but they look at crash density
while we look more at road features
so we can we think that's an opportunity
to offer a different perspective
we can also potentially add an
additional feature that they might be
looking at because of the way that we do
the analysis where every feature is kind
of snapped
to a road segment and isn't as density
dependent
um it's also really fun this when we
reached out to austin
we were able to compare notes and share
and learn and might even be
applying for some type of grant together
um
and the other thing too is whenever a
city already has
um a digital platform that's similar
that's in line with kind of a vision
zero policy goals
we are the cross data is usually open
and available
some of the cities haven't had the
resources or in-house tech expertise to
create this type of platform we view
this as another opportunity and that's
actually where we're focusing a lot of
our outreach
um i think one thing to emphasize is
that a city government
partner does not have to be the
government um and multiple stakeholders
may add value to contextualizing the
model output so
if you're part of a bicycle coalition if
you're part of like kind of a moms
or in father's group one thing that we
have run
into is that the crash data may not be
as easily available we've created a form
that people can fill out on our website
that i'll also link in some of my tweets
um and put in the chat later um that
people can fill out to see if we can try
to help them
one kind of funny story with that is
that somebody i think they were in
florida
was very interested but all the crash
data was on floppy disk
so um they were not as accessible so i
think this is where we like also really
support
value-wise this idea of like open data
um and also this idea of local
sustainability so when a local group
also like kind of partners and joins our
slack channel and is really involved in
their particular city we think that
that's really exciting
um so this is kind of the the meta part
but if we think about what a city is
um we're the city right so it's not just
a city government
um i had a little bit of fun looking up
the origin of the word city in latin and
then also
uh because it means citizen we also
really support residents of cities
acknowledging that not everybody has had
the privilege of citizenship
in the us and other countries and
i really loved that in greece they
really um
in ancient greece which is also kind of
the seat of where like at least we
perceive democracy to come from
then um we the the citizen was also like
the most basic
uh unit of the city um and on that note
um especially because we grew out of a
group called data for democracy and
really still support uh some of the
values of democrat democratic
participation
is that we want to support the local
participation
and hope that the expertise of the
public and civic participation
and democracy as practice and open
source and open data projects are really
part of that
we hope that this provides kind of an
open transparent way to link
data and data analysis to advocacy and
policy
that being said um this is a little bit
of a kind of interpretation
it also means that when we seek a
government partner
then one of the things that is part of
that partnership is that there has to be
trust in the expertise of the public
support for pacific participation and
understanding that democracy can be an
innovative practice
which often includes like seeding some
of the power of
having access to data or even access to
analysis of policy
um so that accessibility is really
really key if your data is on floppy
disk it's harder to get access to i
really want to emphasize too
uh i admire a lot taiwan as a leader in
digital and collaborative democracy
particularly with kova they've really
opened
kind of their technology doors and let
citizens really directly hack
um into many different types of support
systems
um i'm going to just list the menu of
options for city partners one thing that
we found when we were reaching out to
cities
is that it was also helpful for us to
say like exactly what we could offer
instead of having kind of an open
conversation and not assuming that a
city could like immediately look at like
our github or a website and know
what we could potentially um provide um
so
one is that cities sometimes we have
this forum where they can let us know
they're interested
if they already have crash data one of
the options we say is we can actually
load it initialize it run it through our
platform and
generate the data vis and the risk
scores which is one of
our outputs um if there's a particular
policy question we really love it if
they ask the question and we see if our
data can actually support answering that
and kind of thinking through that um and
then the other thing
specifically um this picture here is in
austin
and we were having a little bit of fun
reaching out to austin
the um the information like the gray
like node is a voting booth so this is
around the time of the election and we
were curious
um what the like higher risk routes to
get to the voting booths or not where
and we were thinking about this in kind
of terms of like
accessibility so like if a polling
location
um is not accessible to some
neighborhoods because or it's more
dangerous to get there this might tell
us
some of the ways that like things can be
just resources can be distributed
throughout the city
um the other thing too that i think is
really cool the output
is basically a segment and a risk score
and a
lot long we can
combine that particular segment and risk
scores with other data so we've begun to
look at census data
understand equity concerns and those are
some of the many projects that i'm
getting to experiment a little bit as i
grow my my coding knowledge
in r as well um again
we are a volunteer run organization so i
told my team that we also
are actively would share that we're
actively seeking uh volunteers
um one thing that i think has made this
project so
sustainable for such a long time i mean
it's really been three or four years of
people having near
weekly meetings um is that we try to
create a really sustainable practice so
it's less based on
uh hackathons and more based on kind of
like kind of the slow
paced work of getting a little bit of
done every week also i will say the
documentation and this is not on me this
is really
i have to think jenny our data engineer
is excellent
um and i think one thing with the pace
matching with partners is that um
compared to maybe startups it may appear
that governments move
more slowly but a lot of this is has to
do with just like kind of the
um structure with which it's set up and
we
really are happy to like support and
match that um type of consideration
and and cycle um and let me check time
i'm okay
um and so this is to get in checked uh
the best way to communicate with us is
really our slack channel which you can
find on our website
at the bottom um you can also write us
or fill out a google form to
try to onboard your city and we'll get
out to you twitter
which we set up in order to pilot uh
this launch with cities
is a great way to i manage the twitter
account and then our email
will get forwarded to to all of us so i
do appreciate that
all right uh i don't think i can see the
chat as a speaker
um but hopefully people wrote some stuff
in there
and kind of shared their city um like
full disclosure if you shared a city i
might be reaching out to you to see if
you would want to onboard it or work
on the project in any particular way
because i think that's can be really
exciting and give a lot of insight
into basically future analysis and then
also
um different policies or supporting kind
of the vision zero initiative
that your city may or may not have
adopted um
yeah so that's about it let me look on
twitter
and i was given a recommendation to talk
to the ped net coalition so thank you
stuss
appreciate that okay
that's that that's it so thank you so
much and have a lovely day
thank you very much that was wonderful
you know
i like imagine a lot of people here are
city dwellers
and make good use of alternate modes of
transportation they'll call it whether
it's
subway bus or bicycle why that's called
alternate i don't really know why cars
get priority
you know i get around primarily by a
foot
bicycle and subway so that's great for
me
and we have come